hey guys it's dense the founder fake
kara and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of the walking dead season
4 episode 8 too far gone the mid-season
finale yeah now the one that it's been
building up for and I had to say
actually really liked this episode the
one caveat I have for it is not really
the episode it's this should have been
the season 3 finale yes yes they didn't
need all that build-up some people will
say well yeah they need all not really
if you had just taken the same story
that happened in season 3 and just fit
it to what happened in this episode
right I think it would have worked just
fine I think it hurt some of them
motivations for this episode I think I
mean when in the comic the town of
Woodbury attacks yes the prison you get
why they're upset you can understand
because you know the governor is crazy
he wrought up all these people but the
fact that he got this is a little new
family to rally and attack the prison
you know I mean I like really that fast
it's like you really be like we need to
attack this prison I realized that the
governor has some charisma can I get it
but I don't I didn't understand the
motivations behind them attacking that
so I realized that once the attack
happened some people had second thoughts
one girl was freaking out like good just
cut somebody's head off you know so i
don't know i didn't get the motivations
like i said i wish this would have
happened with the town of Woodbury at
the end of season yeah it would have
made more sense well that's what is so
on we both have read the comic book
right you've gone further your I think
we're caught up with him yeah yeah for
me where this episode ends is where my
comic book reading has ended so I knew
that there was gonna be a big battle
with the tank with the governor some
differences and I knew who's gonna die
or maybe he thought he was gonna die
because some of the stuff that happens
in the comic book doesn't happen in
certain characters die in the contract
that don't die in the show and some
people that died on the show don't die
in the copyright this case Herschel does
die yes differently I won't spoil
anything there's a character who is
beheaded in that scene in the comic book
who's still alive knock I say who but if
they flipped it around I'm always fine
with I'm always fun with them yeah I
didn't have a issue with that and then
you had the gun
nurs death which it was kind of a
two-part like it was Michonne through
the through the chest but then it was
really at the end Lily with the gun see
his face I got asked this I know this
stupid-ass this is a practical question
to show this base on a post-apocalyptic
world filled with zombies but how did
the girl does she walk with the little
girl I mean she said like the prisoners
off of highway something something that
makes it seem like it's several miles
she walk with the girl in her arms the
whole way I'm assuming she drew a real
crowd the guy was to spend to leave a
little bit I get it but this is kind of
fun but the governor's death in the comp
oak is much more gruesome oh yeah
definitely definitely with them with
Michonne yeah yeah so I guess maybe for
the television purposes there yeah it
shows AMC can't go too far right yeah
it's oh so what would you think about
that episode as a whole I mean did you
like it I I thought it was good I i
think there's moments when i was watches
I think maybe I'm too far gone with this
series uh this was a good episode I
don't want to take away from that there
were moments I lied to moments I didn't
like I said that the motivation with the
carriers I didn't get why they would
rile up and be like we got to take this
prison with a tank I mean he's like
we'll need to hurt anybody no one needs
to get hurt but you have a tank it's
like come on I mean you're trying to
make you're trying to make a statement
with that um I it's just I'm really up
having trouble this whole season is
getting into the characters I don't know
who I really care about I like the
governor likes it i think the governor
is better like you and i both of you
think the governor's better in the
series TN series that in the comics he's
way more fleshed out i think david moore
she did an excellent job portray i'm
kind of sad that he's gone I'm said the
governor's gone yeah yeah he has more
dimension to he's not the the governor
in Congress much more like hahaha I'm an
evil bastard villain where where this
one there are moments of humanity
in goodness yeah in him yeah but then
you also see his craziness and no kind
of Herschel's head and and you know once
he found out that the daughter is like
surrogate daughter which was gonna was
gonna turn into zombies and I am and
that's what worries me about this series
a little bit is the whole shock value I
don't know how far they can push it i
mean i don't they trying to go for the
whole game of thrones saying i mean you
have a little girl she was just playing
on that mud and she was i was waiting
for a zombie to come like she's dead I
mean this is you kind of knew it was
coming and then with little kids
shooting an adult he knows a little like
cute little girl shoot an adult I mean I
don't know if I'm supposed to feel an
emotion when I see that like oh my gosh
those little kids like I feel so like
how dark they've turned but i'm like i
don't i don't have an emotional
connection to them so i don't i don't
really feel anything towards that's that
those are the parts of the episode where
I was like I just couldn't get into it
but I think it was a big improvement
definitely a big improvement subs yeah I
like you know I like you know Maggie's
reaction to to her father's death yeah
bats reaction and they all kind of went
crazy they had run around I mean with
not miss Russell it was chaos yeah
because they see this thing happening
from so far away all right they can't do
anything about it and they're firing the
guns and then you know with the tank
blowing up like the prison left and
right yeah gates falling down zombies
coming in like it's just it's just
craziness so I running around but before
that we had I thought when when Rick
told Darrell about Carol I thought that
know that Daryl would have a more
stronger reaction yeah he cares for her
he was upset but he you know like I
thought he might have like gotten really
upset yeah going gone to blows and break
even liar she didn't do that you know
that type of thing all right I'm denial
right he kind of accepted at the same
time you know he's still angry about it
but he kept it in check and they said
well we better tell Tyreese though and
of course diaries never finds out no cuz
explosion oh wait sorry we got to go I
got check out what's going on outside ya
know
the other day I mean I thought euro
would react a little differently I mean
there had some nice moment since episode
of course we put the zombie as a shield
and I was full-grown the grenade down to
goodnight shoot Charlie from fringe
Charlie go that's okay uh he's good I
mean Darrell is always a badass is a
good character Michonne had some good
moments I still don't know if I care
about Carl like rooms like borrow Carl's
like I had a kid could be dead you know
and this is my problem this is not this
not this shows fall in the comic book
Carl is still a little guy like I was re
read volume 8 far too far to go too far
gone and Carl's like a little guy and
he's like gotta be nine ten he's a
little guy but I mean you know kids at
puberty they grow I get it season four
says like for you right it's not the
kids fault in a comic you can draw the
kid the same way over and over again so
he seems so much older but I like him as
a little kid and all the stuff he has to
go through seems so much more intense
whereas on the show I'm like okay now
he's just kind of annoying at a lesson
he still a trigger-happy remember is a
shooting people well he's like oh should
we just shoot him like I got no I gotta
go I could shoo to be done my legs and
you know far you are you're not gonna
hear Daryl says you can't make that shot
you can't make that shot yeah so little
trigger happy but at the end he did take
care of business it was it was she got
it done zombies you know is both him his
father were distraught over over um well
do tourism disappearance we can't say
death Rex little girls well you had hell
yeah you had the the baby basket yeah
well girl honey but she's not there so
we'll tell you what happens in conflict
because it's not gonna happen like right
so in the comic book of lori is running
a live running with the baby weight
she's pregnant yet no she had the baby
yeah yes yes baby his baby in her arms
and he's shot you just see this is full
page of her in his blood and then like
this and then yeah so she's she's gone
yeah so Laurie is still alive in the
competition wins she's carrying the baby
and she gets shot like with the sniper
like her and the baby he's there get
blood sweater yeah so it's not a spoiler
because we don't know was always dead so
she Corey's dad and in this one we don't
know what happened to do right cuz
there's no body Britt was just some
blood we don't you know maybe someone
took her
maybe she's on the bus yeah we don't
really know exactly who's on the bus cuz
the bus takes off before we see who's on
it right you know we know that Glenn was
on it we don't know if he ever got off
hmm we don't know if Maggie got off is
still not it I like those moments
between Maggie and Glenn those are two
characters at caribou I care about Daryl
yeah you know I care about Rick and Carl
a little bit yeah Carl he knows me
sometimes but maybe you know right I
think they had a moment in this episode
that i think was good so I mean because
this the story for the second half of
the the complet to spoil anything is
really straight about Rick and his son I
mean he meets other people of course is
always new encounters who things going
on but it's really about Rick and Carl I
miss I miss Andrea in this cuz Andrew
the badass like she was sniping in the
comic book she snipe and she's kill
she's you know still around andrea is
great it's too bad they kind of ruined
her character but it was still good this
was what I wanted at the end of season 3
they deliver good action yeah a lot of
action good I mean good set pieces good
story it did a good job overall this is
a good episode of thing yeah I think
they just they should have just made
this the season 3 right and then all
that kind of stuff beforehand didn't
really need to be there because if you
think about the end of this episode
could have been achieved back man oh
yeah definitely yeah that's me so
alright guys so that's what we thought
of the mid-season finale of The Walking
Dead doesn't come back until February's
a break yeah let us know what you think
you can post your constable on the
website thank yo calm or on our YouTube
channel think hero pro make sure you
subscribe to that you also can find us
on Twitter we'll talk to Dennis and I
but what how are you going to spend your
time between now and forever there are
other shows to watch people there are
other shows out there besides the
walking dead so feel free to chat with
us let us know what you want to watch
you want any advice on what to watch
will tell you we're at think hero i'm at
griffin diggie and we also have a
Facebook page that's facebook.com slash
think hero fans and make sure you like
that page and you share our video tweet
it out put a post it on Facebook that
really helped us out
you